very exciting day for us here in cologne
uh we're going to announce today that
we are going to have our entire
passenger vehicle range electrified
by mid 2026 what we mean by that is
all-electric
or plug-in hybrid across the range
and all electric for passenger cars by
2030.
that is that is correct yes and tell us
about
um commercial vehicles i know you're a
big manufacturer of those
they're obviously bigger vehicles they
go longer distances you can see
some obvious challenges there with the
electrification strategy what's your
target there
well samantha we're the number one uh
brand in europe for commercial vehicles
we have been for
six consecutive years and we're gonna
electrify or have electrified options on
the entire
range by the end of 2024 and we expect
two-thirds of our sales to be
electrified by uh 2030 again
all electric or plug-in hybrid vehicles
so all are
all in on both passenger and commercial
vehicles
that's quite a seismic shift for the
business a massive investment as i was
mentioning earlier 22 billion dollars
how are you funding that
yeah so 22 billion dollars globally and
obviously a significant piece of that
here in europe that's going to be funded
through
cash flow from operations uh our
business is
uh healthy we've been recovering
strongly in europe as we've turned
around our
operations here over the last uh two
years a very exciting day for us here in
forth of europe
and you're standing there talking to us
in cologne that is going to be the
center of your
electrification in europe
why germany why not the uk
so um yes i'm here in uh neil assembly
plant in cologne this has been our
home in germany now for over 90 years
and this is the first
uh plant that we're going to electrify
here in europe building an all-electric
vehicle from 2023
obviously uk hugely important market for
us as well and
our team in dunton will be contributing
strongly leading the engineering of our
commercial vehicles including the
electrification of those products
so we will see the manufacture of those
of those cars coming off the conveyor
belts
in the uk as well so we produce
uh powertrains in in the uk and we have
our
engineering center and our headquarters
for our commercial vehicle business
in dunton in south east setting so we
don't produce
uh vehicles but it's a very important
part of our overall operation
the race is on isn't it uh you're not
the first
big automotive company to make an
announcement like this the race is on
to really uh get there with the
electrification
of of your vehicles it's also on to
develop
better batteries they're still very
expensive aren't they a fully electric
car even a mid-sized one is very
expensive for people
how do you get a mass-market electric
car to be affordable and make any money
on it
well you're right samantha the european
region is really uh leading the way in
the electrification of our industry and
obviously as we
invest heavily not only for but the
entire industry
as part of that we will be bringing down
costs as we establish
uh scale and move into the more uh
volume parts of the market but our
objective is to make these products
affordable for everybody so that
everybody can
come on this journey with us and with
your electrification
program how does that change if at all
uh your requirement for labor and and
the skills of the people
that you employ
yeah so it's obviously a huge uh
transition for ford and
the entire industry as we move from
conventional
power trains engines transmissions to
batteries so we've worked very closely
with our
social partners here in germany but also
in the uk and in spain
to manage that transition in an
appropriate
way and we get great uh support it's a
big change
and uh we've you know we've made good
progress already but we have more work
still ahead of us do you see job losses
as a result
we'll continue to resize our operations
we've been able to make
the changes we need to make so far on a
voluntary basis and
that remains our objective as we go
forward
okay so you're not ruling out uh more
job losses then
yeah we would expect to see some
continued uh descaling in our in our
european operations as we
as we make this transition that's
correct uh can you give us an idea
percentage of workforce
no we're not uh we're not sharing that
over the last two years um we
reduced our workforce in in europe by
about 20 or
10 000 uh people and we continue to work
with our social partners first to
have those discussions and make sure we
make these changes
in a very yeah okay and stuart i've got
to ask you i mean i know that you
welcomed the 11th hour trade deal
the brexit trade deal you're opening
well you're focusing
your your efforts for this latest uh
latest strategy in germany what has the
reality
been for you as an exporter since since
the trade deal
yeah so uh well we absolutely uh welcome
the uh the fda between the uk and the eu
as well as
importantly for us between the uk and
turkey what that has meant is
we've been able to continue to sell our
our vehicles uh free of tariffs across
the range we've seen some
i would say uh minor uh delays on
getting you know after-market parts uh
into the uk but we're working
you know closely with their customers to
make sure that we
uh we speed that up but we're very we're
very pleased with the
uh with the outcome and to both the eu
and the uk for reaching those agreements
all right but still a bit of a friction
that you're acknowledging there and
finally front page of the ft today
talking about employers in the uk
uh perhaps moving to a contract basis
with their workforce
no jab no job just wanted to get your
perspective on that
yes i i mean our point of view uh
samantha is that it's a personal choice
we will um you know we will educate will
encourage employees to
take up the opportunity for a vaccine
but we don't intend to mandate